where's the blacksmith was the
blacksmith where's the blacksmith well
boy I found you Black's milk anyway hi
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to let's play losses okay
someone wrote me a really nice email
telling me that I was a stupid idiot and
missed a whole bunch of things so I
found the blacksmith because he has a
horseshoe on his door he's kind of on
this hidden path here but also there was
a blue screwdriver that was behind the
house that I needed to go back and open
that radio that we had found in the
other place to get a magnet for
something that's where the letter ended
he was like thank you for nothing you
stupid douche sincerely a J Bo 969 oh
yeah so anyway we got the blacksmith
here so hahaha I'm genius
I'm genius i broom you up a rake it
could be useful anything else that's
useful it's random tools new this is
this a vise it used to hold objects
firmly like a magnet this won't do
can't use this here okay I'll keep that
in mind for later I've got a rake for
some all right no not the rake was that
it is that really it
all I needed in here was a rake I really
just needed a rake you can't be serious
what am I gonna do with a rake I don't
even get a key there's got to be like a
key or something here I have no idea
what what what where where a big baby
where who is this oh it's nothing it's
just a log what about over here what is
this no in case you're running hello
minigame OOP I missed oh god I am
terrible oh ah screw you okay anyway so
if you're wondering the
broken okay no fixing that the
screwdriver was in this little bin
behind house by this generator so um I
have anymore keys I found this
mysterious locked gate should I use the
rake on it and climb over this won't do
can't use this here I've got now I've
got a rake now I'm a maniac with a rake
where do I use this rake why is he
holding a ring well I use the rake why
okay so I wandered around here for a
while - that's just the amphitheatre up
there I didn't see anything youthful
over there um the rope ladder and a dead
end is over here so maybe there's
something that I can I'm gonna grab with
the rake I'm guessing probably in a
crevice of some sort I have no idea
really but I've learned that in these
games you use everything on everything
without any question of logic doesn't
have to make sense doesn't even have to
do anything with reality
it's just use everything on everything
so I'm gonna take this rake which is the
only new thing that I've gotten and I'm
going to use it on everything so here we
go rake on rope ladder rake on wall rake
on thing on ground rake on spot on
ground break on everything rake on
everything
maybe Howard no no I don't know I'm not
gonna overthink it I'm just gonna use
everything I'm gonna use the magnet on
the rope ladder and then I'm gonna tie
the magnet to the rake on everything and
then keep going forward I'm gonna jump
off to my death that's why I'm gonna do
cuz I can't take the stress of this game
anymore I can't do it don't make no
sense
break on rope ladder rake out rope
ladder nothing nothing absolutely
nothing well you're useless to me
are you even clicking what
how does that make sense what what did
you even know what the hell just
happened what has happened I couldn't
jump up that I thought what no I I
didn't make any sense at all
can I get that did I get to break no
I've lost the rake the rake is gone
forever I can't I can't possibly get the
rake back from that exercise of nonsense
I've seen a lot of nonsensical things
but that had to be the most nonsensical
it's locked
surprise surprise did I come up here for
nothing cuz they don't have another key
whose oh it's an outhouse no need to go
in there uh why is our grass growing on
the roof what is this place why am I
here where's my lantern and a rope
ladder need to find a way to get up
there you couldn't you know like jump
game logic game logic gotta use a rake
to get up a ladder make sense to me
alright okay
I read Tara riff okay so I don't see
anything here can't get in the window
maybe there was something in here hello
oh there we go stick your hand right in
there
I can see something shining at the
bottom but I'm not getting my hands in
there what stop being a baby stop being
a little baby I need something to help
me put me oh why why
maybe the magnet uh uh that's why I need
the magnet yep there we go
let's see if this will work really
you're that squeamish that you can
alright well I guess if you have a
magnet that's fine but it's a key
goody-goody is it the key to this house
that would be awfully convenient
alright key to house key to a house and
go yep
alright why does my Lantern keep going
out when those cutscenes happen okay
shovel okay the dirt pile the dirt pile
I could shovel the dirt pile now that
makes sense that makes sense
I understand that
an old oven turn on the old oven dish
silverware click on everything make sure
nothing could possibly be missed
anything
oh that's what what why would you take a
[ __ ] why why would you take Oh ashes
those look useful why why do they you
look beautiful
what's wrong with you a dirty bed oh
geez beggars can't be choosers okay all
started 30 years old when they came to
our village man that is a lot to read
okay if you guys want to read this
because there is a lot here I'm not
gonna waste the time to read it all but
if you guys want to read this pause the
video right now give you some time to
read this as I click what I was Oh click
inside the books ok 1 2 3 click 2 3
click 2 3 strange events local band
mayor and left his house it moved safety
of the city only foreigners didn't
appear to be disturbed by strange event
watching them some nice cross bridge
near the rock one watched him slip made
noise The Heretic want to begin
searching I tried to stay cool despite
the pain from which was an angle he got
a closer suddenly he turned me to look
me straight in the eyes I prepared for
my final exam but he did nothing only
kept staring at me I could see under his
eyes cap looking back with full of
sadness and despair he didn't heard away
others clearing a kiddin house relieved
confused decide to stay in the house for
a few days 5 days passed
woman screaming bed in House of the
mayor not long her knock on door
hesitated open man and woman man badly
hurt home come inside light fell on
man's face recognize he was the one I
encountered a few days ago explaining
they were hiding being chased one but
unborn child dark daddy
Typho yes uh he told me those new
longtime secret too from them tried to
treat his wound already died refuge for
wife and unborn child furtively buried
his body outside the seminary so another
look um taking care of snow nobody could
find her secretly spying on their
activity leader lives in abandoned house
of the mayor secret entrance uh okay I
needed to they call ARIMA perform dark
rituals their purpose is to prepare the
ground
Typho leus learn
can disrupt one sacred item secure it I
will use it to stop one the time's right
okay all right that was a lot I actually
glanced through that a lot more than I
thought I would but anyway that gave
some insight and obviously I need to go
that the body oh hello
the body is um what I need to find in
the woods but it's a long way away oh I
could just done that and the body is
like a long way away a lot of this game
is just a lot of traveling okay I don't
think there's anything else I get the
shovel I got tom ashes why I don't know
I got him okay so let's go we was there
anything else up here here's a log
anything uh uh uh okay all right okay
okay all right okay all right let's get
out of here
no more rake for me I'm moving up in the
world I use a log to get up and down her
I am man no wimpy baby climbing got to
use a log I've racked anyway also I'm
holding on the Run button this entire
time if this is running I will not
question this guy's climbing skills
because obviously this guy has some
trouble so I won't make fun of them okay
is there any reason I should go back
there nope I've got a shovel I'm gonna
dig up that dirt pile I found back in
the first episode and then I'll be able
to carry on into the night doing
anything I want anything the
possibilities are endless is what I
could do apparently
all right
hello music it's about time something
decided to show up it's been awfully
quiet this entire time wait wait whoa oh
it's it's a rock never mind
yeah it's been really quiet this whole
time I don't know why there wasn't any
like music or anything playing oh good
for that and I thought hello owl I
thought I thought when I was reading the
notes when I was first playing this they
said they added NPC threats and so far
I've seen nothing
I've been they've been scared to me
probably because I've been running
around where's your blacksmith I'm gonna
you just rake on the light or I'll take
these ashes Why What Oh use them on my
fire crazy insane monster that I am
nothing I do has made sense so far but
whatever I'm sure it'll make sense later
we're job locksmith hook
alright deviously this is a long run and
I am NOT going very fast so sorry
there's takin so long but man at least I
know where I'm going hey if I didn't
know where I was going I just be
wandering through the entire village
trying to use the shovel on everything I
see and I'd be totally at a loss and you
guys would hate me you probably really
already do hate me okay was over here on
the right side by these rocks somewhere
here here ish where's my lantern oh whoa
yep that's it okay now I got to use this
on that right yeah sure all right yes
gamer skills totally pro okay what is
that can you dig more out or you just go
okay piece of stone part with symbol on
it what do we guys as part of that
that's probably part of the relic that
can interrupt the thing is there more
shovel areas around here god I hope not
because I will stab myself with this
shovel if there are I'm never gonna find
them
oh there are
there oh there were probably shovel
spots all throughout town oh no oh no oh
no as my friend Bob would say oh no oh
the cemetery
I got dig up some bodies in the cemetery
all right I'm not gonna make you guys
wait for me walking through so I'll be
I'll be back as soon as egg in the
cemetery huh brah okay we're at the
cemetery all right let's go disturb some
graves here I just got to start digging
right
start digging everywhere dig dig dig oh
come on I'm comin Oh Rama dabba doo
oh come on there's got to be some here
it's gotta be some here please please
please please
this was my grave that was my coffin
don't know why they didn't kill me
before they buried me I'm talking about
grave okay okay y'all write anything
here
no really this would be the most sound
logic that I could possibly come up with
oh wait a minute
this game doesn't use logic oh that's
right okay I'm right
what oh I was rockin never mind okay
hang on I'll be back in just a second
cuz it's gonna figure out what's goin on
ah-ha-ha-ha okay alright I I just
remembered in the story that the guy had
buried the other guy because he died so
ergo oh I thought this was going to be
the body oh okay well I mean I guess I
got another piece of the stone but all
right then there and wait there's got to
be like a body somewhere with this guy's
buried right right I'm not gonna leave
until I find it because I know that
there's a bunch of other stuff that I'm
overlooking obviously because this game
is extremely complicated complicated
complicated it's got to be here
somewhere I'm not gonna leave until I
find it not [ __ ] with me but
apparently there are places all over
this map all over this map with awesome
hiding spots for those pieces of things
all right it's gotta be here it's gotta
be here it's got to be here it's got to
be here somewhere somewhere so martial
arts from somewhere teddy bear teddy
bear oh I'm gonna have an aneurysm I'm
gonna have an aneurysm looking for this
stuff all right hang on I'll find it in
a second just give me a moment huh ah
wow what the hell is that that's a wolf
whatever hey get away get away get away
get away get away get away get away get
away I'll get you up on this log here ah
God ah ah
oh I could not get on the log what that
is friggin stupid okay I couldn't find
anything up here now there's a figured
wolf dog ah I guess that's the NPC
threat they created arbitrarily while
I'm wandering aimlessly into the woods
ah I'm gonna find this I was headed back
to the cemetery case you guys were
wondering okay he's still there okay
alright this time get on the log get on
the log and then don't die don't be
stupid
get on the frickin log get out of hog
then you get up the log where is he yeah
you better run too tough for you [ __ ]
doing it oh come on
what about to do
hi puppy Poochie come Heather top Bing
dick be less of dick as I run around you
I go around you know beginning ah
alright I'm done for now
I've been wandering through this game
for way too long way too long and now
that I do though okay so I'll turn it
back to the cemetery I'm gonna look more
there cuz there's got to be a body in
the cemetery that's just only logic that
I'm gonna I know this game doesn't use
logic I know I know
I know this I know this but there's got
to be something right okay so anyway I'm
done for now got forever I'm done for
now so anyway I've got a pile of ash got
a screwdriver and a shovel and now
there's a wolf trying to murder my face
off okay so anyway thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
use it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
in China
ah
ah
bud
that's not